[Music]
hello everyone my name is David course
shade I work at Microsoft and I am so
excited to be here again in Prague the
last time I was here I talked to you all
about state charts and state machines
and how they could help influence the
way that we do developments in a
positive way and today on Halloween
which is why I'm wearing this costume
I'm going to be talking to about
mind-reading with intelligence and
adaptive user interfaces and so the
thing is with Halloween a lot of people
you might you know might celebrate here
I don't know I saw a few people in
costumes so especially at this
conference and we saw that a lot of
people just like to dress as something
that they're not and part of it is to
express their own creativity or just
something that they like and that's the
important thing is that everyone is
different and this is something that we
have to keep in mind when we're
developing applications and user
interfaces because we all speak
different languages we all come from
different backgrounds so in my opinion
when we do things like a be tests or
funnel charts or funnel diagrams I feel
like that sort of disingenuous and
ineffective because those only target
certain people and we make assumptions
about the people that were developing
our apps for and also the thing is that
the user flows that are represented in
our app are not always linear in fact
users could do so many different things
and we have to represent those in
different ways so one example of an
adaptive user interface is guest j/s
which was made by I believe Sam Saucony
at Google and this uses predictive
analytics to intelligently prefetch
resources on the page depending on where
the user is likely to end up next and so
this contributes to a positive user
experience because when the user visits
a web page then they are going to be
able to see the next web page loaded a
lot faster than if they had to wait to
load the resource
so this gets to the core of what
adaptive user interfaces are you might
have heard of responsive user interfaces
which adapts to devices whether you have
a laptop a desktop with your crazy
60-inch monitors or a cell phone or even
the Apple watch or Google if they're
still doing watches but the key is that
adaptive interfaces adapts to us we are
the device in which is interacting with
the application and so one of the
earliest examples of this
you might remember is Clippy from
Microsoft I'm legally obligated to
include him in this in this slide so it
would take for example email a user
comes into this interface and is
presented with an inbox in which they
could choose in action to do they could
view the latest messages or they could
compose a new email and so while we
might try to make a one-size-fits-all
user interface that solves all the
problems with with different users using
the app we might see that users use it
differently in this case this user might
always try to view the latest email or
when the user composes a new email then
they might be more likely to send the
email rather than save it as drafts so
those are user flows that we could
optimize for another example is in the
Google inbox interface where instead of
asking are you sure when you're deleting
a message or when you're sending a
message instead we could reduce that and
create a more adaptive user interface by
saying it's deleted and giving them the
option to undo that and this completely
eliminates a step in the user flow which
is very good for the user because
they're able to do their actions a lot
more efficiently so another example in
in Google inbox I don't know if you've
seen this feature but I use this all the
time is when you're composing a new
message you see that it will actually
predict the next thing that you're going
to type and sometimes it's not exactly
why I want to type I'm lazy so I choose
Google's suggestion anyway
and you know the same thing happens in
messages and you know maybe iPhone will
do this one day too or I was gonna say
Microsoft but that doesn't really exist
so also adaptive user interfaces can
adapt to whether your user is a power
user and knows all the function now that
you're ready so you want to provide
these power shortcuts for them to
achieve their tasks as quickly as
possible or maybe the user needs a
little bit more guidance and so when the
adaptive user interface can detect that
and actually provide that guidance and
help them achieve the same goals
however developing adaptive user
interfaces definitely has its challenges
with adaptive user interfaces there's a
lot of factors we need to take into
consideration including user privacy
whether we wants to adapt at the local
level or in a global level such as
adapting via routes versus you know
adapting singular components or you know
whether we want to you know provide the
user an option to change it via settings
so do we want to give the user manual
control or do we want this to happen
behind the scenes so one way that we
could tackle this problem and actually
introduce adapt abuser in their faces in
our everyday development is by adopting
what's called model driven development
which is not a new concept at all so the
idea is that you represent your
application as an abstract model now if
you've been doing design are working
with designers
you might recognize something called
user flows and so these are they're
technically a form of abstract models
which tell you which state goes to which
next state in the application and it's a
very visually clear way to represent how
your user is going to interact with the
application now last year I talked about
finite state machines and state charts
and this is a way that we could
introduce these abstract models into our
applications in case you forgot so I'll
just do a little bit of a reminder a
finite state machine has an initial
state such as a sign-in page
it has a finite number of states which
represents all of the possible states
that a user can be in when they're
interacting with your app it has a
finite number of events which represents
everything that could happen within the
app whether that action is initiated by
the user or within the app itself it has
a mapping of state transitions which are
triggered by these events and so these
are deterministic and they say when were
in one state such as the sign in States
and an event happens such as sign in now
we're on the signing in state and so
these arrows are going to be very
important and there's also a finite
number of final states which say the the
user has completed this flow or we're
done or this app is at its terminal
points and you would have to restart or
do something else to start the app over
again now why do we use finite state
machines well if you look at my talk
last year it's to prevent impossible
states such as this one
now state charts are an extension of
finite States and state charts have a
lot more features that we're not going
to get into right now because I don't
have time but the idea is that using
these concepts such as finite state
machines and state charts help prevent
impossible States and help you make
sense of your application I created X
State which which is a way of coding
these state charts into your application
and it has all these sorts of features
and if you don't need these features
then there's other options as well such
as x8 FSM which is just for the finite
state machine but long story short go
check out X state because it's going to
be a great way for you to represent your
state's also there's X dates for react
as well I haven't released version 1 yet
but a lot of people are using the use
machine hook in production right now and
so the idea is you would have this use
machine hook you would you would use it
just like a used reducer hook and use it
directly within your application now X
it could also be used with you
angular spelt all these other things I
don't have official plug-ins for these
quite yet just because
don't tell the reacting but it just
works so with with react we sort of had
to make it happy with hooks and so the
idea is that we're trying to prevent
this leak of faulty logic edge cases and
race conditions instead of just lapping
a disabled button everywhere and having
that be the end of that so let's take an
example application let's say that we
have this this feedback form where
you're asked how is your experience the
user could click good in which it says
things for your feedback or the user
could click bad in which it says tell me
why and then there's an option for the
user to fill out the form so this is
what that looks like you have a good
says thanks for your feedback again it's
a very very simple form you can say know
it submit thanks for your feedback
nothing too difficult to to code but
we're moving beyond just coding now we
want to create an adaptive user
interface so here's a game plan first we
want to represent this app as an
abstract model of course that's using
state machines and state charts then
we're going to use transition analytics
to determine the just the frequency of
how often the user goes from one state
to the next state and then we identify
the paths that could be adaptive and
improve the user experience and use the
analysis from step two in that
adaptation feeding it back in real time
so we need a few concepts to learn in
order to do this first one is weighted
graphs you might have learned this in
school but if you haven't it's actually
a pretty simple concept let's say that
when you're signing in you could be in a
success date or a failure state in which
case you're not able to sign in so what
you could do is you can measure how
frequently do users actually go from one
state to the next States and so by doing
that now you have a weight on that edge
and you can represent it visually like
this so our applications can be
represented by these weighted graphs in
a way that we could visually see what
are the most
frequently traverse paths throughout the
application that users would go through
and so a a path a diagram that looks
like this might end up looking like this
in reality in which we could see that
some of the states aren't really
traversed quite the same now in Visual
Studio Live cher I actually used this
technique in the state machine that was
used within BS code and we were able to
measure just how frequently users were
either signing in sharing a session
adjoining a session whether we had a
high frequency of errors are not in a
very visually clear way that connected
all the dots you know based on how the
application worked okay so let's make
this adaptive let's say that when the
user clicks bad we want to sort of give
them the option to either fill out the
form or not so let's take a look at how
that might work what we could do is we
can measure each of the paths taken and
hopefully prints of the demo gods here
so for example when you click good in
reload we measure the count so this is
just a very simple example but let's say
I click bad and I see this form I don't
want to fill out this form so I just
exit and so let's say that I keep having
a bad experience but I really don't want
to fill out the form and so this isn't
good because this is an incomplete user
flow but you see when we have an
adaptive user interface we could
actually you see what just happened
there we could actually redirect the
user to a different state and so this is
easily done with these state machines
and state charts because we have these
paths represented as directed graphs and
now we could just measure in the debt in
real time based on what the users
actions are so this is a way of
analyzing by transitions and you could
probably think of many more applications
in which you could do this for example
if you're on Instagram and you see when
the user logs in that the most frequent
state that they go to next
is the camera instead of the gallery of
the profile you could shortcut the fact
that when they login they go directly to
the camera instead of what are their
whatever other default state that they
might be in now decision trees can also
be useful in in determining which paths
we wants to take and so I'm not going to
go through this but there's a lot of
useful info in towards data science
which I'm going to be mentioning later
in this talk as well now prediction can
also be done via shortest paths which
I'm also not going to get into but we
could use this analytics tracking within
within our services so for example the
next state we have this on transition
callback which this is the only place in
which we're tracking analytics because
that's the singular place in which all
state transitions are represented in
other words what this means is you don't
need to litter your entire application
with analytics or telemetry calls you
have one single place to do it
and so you would provide a target event
a source and possibly the time stamp for
that event to happen so let's sort of
think about some future ideas for
analysis as well higher order Markov
models are a very interesting topic
because what they represent is let's say
you have a weighted graph in which
you're in state a and you're measuring
whether you go to state B or C so it
might seem that overall the the user
goes from A to B most often but if
they're coming from D then they might go
to see more often and so that sort of
changes the dynamic of how the user
actually behaves with the application
also store of a crazy concept but using
deep reinforcement learning within your
applications you could actually measure
and train an agent to determine which
which path is the most likely path a
user is going to take and so that's done
by the agents just experimenting and
saying I think they're going to go here
and then what the user actually does is
fed back into the
and are either rewarded or punished
based on whether the user actually takes
that action and so we could feed that
into our environments which is the
abstracts model that we've created and
use that to sort of adapt the user
interface in real time so you might be
thinking wait seriously like can I can
we really use reinforcement learning in
the browser while the user is
interacting with the app and yes you can
you're just gonna have to sort of take
my word for it all right actually fine
let's see a demo so if you remember from
last year I made this tic-tac-toe app
using finite state machines because
that's sort of my brand but you can see
that this is just a normal tic-tac-toe
game in which player X player Oh can
play but what you might not know how am
i terrible detecto player all right
there we go we drew but what you might
not know is that we could capture
analytics on what the user is most
likely to do so if I turn on the
frequency here I could see that the user
is most likely to click for example the
center one and then from here we played
a bunch of games here and so you know
I'll just play here we could see that
even in bored states that we don't
really we haven't really represented or
played yet that those are all grayed out
but when we reset we could see that
things that we played again it shows up
you know in the frequency of you to the
squares so let's take this to the next
level let's actually introduce a
reinforcement learning agent and have it
predict all of those unknown game states
so what it's going to do is it's going
to behave like a human so it might not
be the best AI but it will it will try
its best so what it's going to do is
it's going to play like a human and you
could see those learning values over
here on each of the squares and then I
could play against it let's say I play
here and you see it shows the most
frequently traversed path so now let's
say I do something
new I go over here it's still going to
try to adapt based on how the users have
actually played and so in other words we
have created a reinforcement learning
agent right in the browser and I'm going
to share this code after the demo so and
of course if it failed I have a video to
show you so the good news is that this
does work and the bad news is that when
I was trying this out a hundred times
last night I got this bail to compile
error and react of course but I got it
because I had no space left on my device
I'm not sure whether that's the thoughts
of my analytics tool or my actual
computer so again the idea is that we
have an application we represent it as
an executable model and then we use this
metric tracking in real-time within our
model and potentially even feed it to
something like Google Analytics
KISSmetrics segments do Mixpanel
or even as your analytics and then we
feed that back into the application and
feed it into these adaptive transitions
within our app and then we have an
adaptive user interface that works in
real-time so this is great in the
process of having a great dev experience
but also using your dev experience to
create a great user experience as well
because when we go from having the
determinism of state machines to having
the way to simulate how users are going
to behave with our app through
simulation and analytics then we
ultimately can create a great user
experience and go beyond the code that
we just wrote to make the app work and
use that exact same code to actually
improve user experiences so ex-state
does have a lot of utilities and tools
that i've created and I actually just
published Eckstein analytics but do not
use it yet because I do want to figure
out that memory leak problem and so I
would cost
you against that and also the next
version of ex-state 4.7 is coming soon
thank you to Matias for really helping
out with that and so if you want to play
around with that right now you could
just MPM install X date at next and also
the first talk today Gatsby you would be
surprised to know that if you use Gatsby
in the background you are using X date
because Gatsby uses this for it's very
complex build processes which are of
course very very important to making the
dev experience as good as possible which
it is working with Gatsby so there's a
lot of resources if you want to learn
more about working with state charts and
also the documentation czar a good
resource to I actually included embedded
visualizations right within the X State
documentation so go ahead and check that
out and we have a vibrant spectrum
community in which we talk about these
abstract modeling concepts such as state
machine state charts Petri Nets all this
sort of stuff even if it doesn't have
anything to do with X state it's just
these old ideas of state machines and
state charts which have been around for
half a century which are just coming to
light now and being more and more
relevant in the front-end community so
ultimately I wants to make your code do
more
I want your code to actually be able to
analyze have tests automatically
generated have even documentation
automatically generated be able to
simulate how a user behaves in real life
and possibly even predict how users
behave so thank you very much reactive
Compton
[Applause]
David Correy thank you so much we have
some questions for you talking about
DAF steps leading to various usage paths
do you think it would be useful to
adjust the UI even if an app based on
the previous user activity
have you ever interacted with an app
that's just so complex and you find
yourself doing the same steps over and
over again what if those steps could be
automated so I would say that yes it is
very very useful to have these adaptive
paths because ultimately the goal is to
make the user do what they do faster and
better can I write a test that is going
through all possible UI states with x8
how does this approach work with manual
and automated tests yes you can use X
date to do that there's a library called
x8 slash test and I actually gave a
presentation that reacts rally a few
months ago talking about that and it's
called model-based testing which has
also been around for quite a few years
so yes
short answer and the last question is
there a plan to adapt this predictive
design through Microsoft product so I
try to think x8 and Microsoft products
but there's only so much I could do
maybe one day I could talk to them and
hopefully do that thank you so much
David core sheet
[Music]